france 2 france 3 tf1 canal+ arte m6 rfo
20h50 programme unique sur ta munich
tous contre le sida en au même lieu le
zénith patricia charnolé bernard pis ce
souci trouvent déjà
ce sera ce soir beaucoup plus qu'une
grande soirée de télévision au zénith
cet après midi pendant les répétitions
tous étaient conscients que l'émission
n'était pas seulement la réunion
exceptionnelle de toutes les chaînes
nationales mais la mobilisation
collective d'un pays contre la maladie
et l'exclusion
c'est l'espoir cette chanson c'est
l'espoir c'est l'espérance puisque
l'esprit parce que je vais différence
entre les deux mots espérances
pendant plus de quatre heures avec les
vedettes les invités les reportages
christophe dechavanne et frédéric
mitterrand feront passer ce message le
sida et la sphère de tous
la notion d'amusement en a souvent dans
le travail les
j'en avais dit les rentrées d'ailleurs
ne pas proposer un bus bourg
ce sera très concertée comme ça
plusieurs grands thèmes seront abordés
le sida c'est quoi comment ça s'attrape
comment en parler où en est la recherche
comment vivre d'amour autant utile à de
nombreux appels seront lancés pour
collecter des fonds ce sera ce soir à la
télévision un moment de générosité
d'espérance et de fraternité